[Music]
my name is Rohit tal rage' I'm a product
manager on the Google cloud healthcare
and life sciences team I focused
specifically on data governance so I
hope it makes sense why I'm giving the
security and compliance session here
today thanks for joining
I know it's a little bit late in the
afternoon thanks for staying awake I
hope to keep you that way so here you
know today I'm here to kind of talk
about what we call the shared
responsibility model and what that means
is you know when we have customers who
are using a cloud service it's a little
bit different than the older models of
infrastructure such as on-premise right
so when we think about the shared
security model there exists some
responsibilities that fall to the cloud
provider and some responsibilities that
fall to the user or the customer and
this is kind of the frame of reference
for the talk today we'll be going over
you know how Google thinks about health
care compliance with a focus it's
probably on HIPAA and then talking about
what you know you as our users can do
with that context and what else you may
have to think about as you build design
and secure your workloads on Google
cloud for healthcare data all right so
just sending a little bit of context
right health care data is under duress
as I call it right health care
organizations are experiencing on
average more than twice the number of
attacks compared to organizations in
other vertical categories right when we
talk about attacks what are we talking
about all right but before we get to
that let's talk about why this matters
right the cost of a data breach is going
up year over year over year so a study
that was conducted between February of
2017 and April of 2018 calculated that
the average cost of a data breach was
just under 4 million dollars so what is
this cover right this covers the loss of
customers due to reputation loss this
covers you know the data that was
affected potentially fines coming over
that the cost of forensics the cost of
communication to regulators to customers
to affected parties and of course
long-term damages right and long-term
damages to reputation being the prime
a motivator of this cost so when we talk
about causes of data breach it's also
good to know who is experiencing them
right so this startling number over 90%
of healthcare organizations have
experienced a breach in under in within
the last three years and 50% of
healthcare organizations have suffered
five or more breaches in that same time
frame right so when I say healthcare
data is under duress
I hope this doubt comes across right and
again it's it's important to point out
that when we say a breach it's not
necessarily hacking it's not necessarily
malicious it could be a doctor sending a
fax yes of fax to the wrong office it
could be a patient you know sending data
from their doctor to a third party it
could be a doctor you know not disposing
of records appropriately when that
patient leaves the system so it's
important to say that a breach is is a
loaded term right it's both malicious
and anything that's defined in the
regulation all right so let's talk more
about costs right specifically
distributed denial-of-service attacks
which are becoming more and more popular
over time we all remember you know the
distributed denial of service attacks
that took place in the last couple of
years they crippled a number of
institutions they cost about two million
dollars a piece and every 40 seconds a
healthcare organization is hit with a
ransom at ransomware attack and the same
assessment said that one in six
healthcare organizations are affected
okay now that I've scared you a little
bit let's scare you a little bit more so
when we think about the number of
attacks going up right one what one
would assume that the number of
protections is also rising to meet that
increase in attacks actually it's
unfortunately the opposite cyber
security budgets in healthcare
organizations have dropped to just about
3% of total spend this is not to say
that health care organizations budgets
are decreasing overall actually the
amount that healthcare organizations are
spending is increasing year over year
however the amount spent on cyber
security is constant meaning that in
proportion less money as being spelled
spent on increasingly important areas
all right so why is health care a prime
target right I think most people know
this but we'll we'll talk a little bit
into specifics health care data is rich
and when I say the data is rich it means
that I can get data about multiple
aspects of an individual just by
breaching one system right so if we
think about your your email account
maybe that has some personal identifying
information your bank account maybe has
some personal identifying information
but really when you think about those
security questionnaires you fill in
right what was your mother's maiden name
what street did you grow up in where
were your parents born where were you
born there's really only one place where
all of that information is healthcare
records and that means that the total
let's say cost-benefit analysis to a
hacker looking for where do I spend my
hacking monies and time healthcare data
is less protected and more useful
therefore let's look at that right the
other reason why healthcare data is a
prime target is because their data is
stored primarily in legacy system so we
know cybersecurity budgets going down we
talked about that systems are older
easier to breach theoretically and
lastly there's a specific category of
hackers who hack for fun hack to cause
the most damage possible right when we
look at healthcare organizations
taken down by things like want to cry
taken down by things like DDoS attacks
downtime impacts patient safety and
therefore people who get pleasure out of
taking down these organizations are
looking to healthcare because
unfortunately it causes a lot of damage
so you know where can we go from here
right and as I said this this talk will
be focused on what both what Google is
doing in the healthcare compliance and
security space and what you as users of
Google cloud can do to help prevent all
of these types of attacks all right so
level setting I know the you know this
this audience probably knows more than
the average audience about what HIPAA is
and what it entails but HIPAA US
regulation for the protection of
healthcare data known as protected
health information so if you hear me use
the acronym pH I throughout this talk
I'm referring to health care information
as defined under HIPAA but we can
probably generalize that to mean any
sensitive healthcare information
globally the same sort of protections
alright so HIPAA is broken into three
requirements three sections of
requirements we have administrative
safeguards which is basically how you
run your business how you hire people
how you give them access to systems what
they do with those systems whether you
plan for disaster events and then we
have physical safeguards right it's like
how when do you let people into your
buildings where do you store your IT
systems who gets access to your IT
systems before you give a vendor access
to your server closet what you know sort
of processes are in place to make sure
that they're properly vetted and they're
only doing what they should be doing and
lastly the biggest bucket which is where
I'll spend most of the time today is
technical safeguards right so HIPAA
being a slightly older law was not
necessarily created for the cloud
environment however it has been amended
a couple of times to account for higher
tech activities and it has been
interpreted by the government and by you
know industry groups to make sure that
the technical safeguards under HIPAA
have somewhat caught up with growing
technology trends so in terms of what
we'll be talking about today we'll talk
about identity and access control
encryption and transmission protection
audit logging activity lauding logging
and audit control so I'll touch upon
these both you know first from the
Google side and then from the customer
side all right so you know it's
important to talk about HIPAA in HIPAA
BAA when talking about HIPAA the
business associate agreement or baa is
the contract that formalizes the
requirements between the service
provider the business associate and the
covered entity generally the insurance
plan the provider system or the health
care information Clearinghouse right in
this baa basically formalizes the
relationship and says both parties agree
that HIPAA data is being exchanged in
this contract and here are the security
requirements that are in place that
govern the use protection transmission
of that healthcare data it's important
to note that you know google cloud is
one of the few providers that offers a
rigorous enterprise grade baa that
covers a large number of GCP services
and even more than that we do it at no
additional cost to the customer because
we believe that you know security in
health care is not optional right we
shouldn't give you fewer protections
because you're in health care and have a
tight budget so all of our protections
in the BAA are there by default there's
no up charge and specifically it
includes you know any region any instant
size that's covered for the service in
the BAA
and has all the protections around
breach notification and encryption by
default all right so going into detail
right administrative safeguards
what are they this is Google's security
program we design our security system
with with an approach we call defense in
depth so whereas the traditional
security model is you know have a hard
perimeter right make it very hard for
people to get onto your network using
things like tough firewalls VPNs Bastion
hosts you know dedicated machines that
can access that network but you know
think of it like an egg shell right if
you have a hard perimeter but then once
you're inside gooey center so anybody
who gets onto that network can then have
free access to anything that is on the
network your EHR systems your billing
systems you know you name it anything
that's on the network they have if they
can compromise your network instead
Google enforces defense-in-depth by
putting different sort of protections
that are relevant to different attacks
at different levels of the
infrastructure so for example when we
talk about Hardware right Google designs
and plans our own server hardware
storage hardware compute hardware and by
doing so not only do we control the
exact performance of the hardware to
meet the specifications that we need we
can also cut out unnecessary components
and control our supply chain down to
off-the-shelf components reducing vendor
in the middle risk taking it all the way
to the top layer you know we have a
robust identity layer in place that only
allows approved individuals to access
services and only services that have
been approved to communicate with each
other to perform activities with each
other so I won't talk through all of
this slide in detail but this is you
know just trying to say there's a
defense-in-depth approach that is
fundamental to everything we do in
security down from our culture to our
technical controls and our operations
I think it's this slide hopefully should
give you an idea that we understand
security certifications table stakes
right as part of the administrative
actions of running a secure compliance
program Google has gone out and gotten
certifications that are relevant to us
as a cloud provider such as ISO which is
fundamental cloud security and privacy
certifications as well as specific
certifications that are specific to our
customers which helps them grow on
Google cloud so this is things like high
trust this is things like FedRAMP
basically certifications where any
vendor in the chain needs to be
certified so that the one that's
providing the final service to the end
customer can get certified as well all
right continuing on to administrative
activities Google regularly conducts
disaster recovery drills by simulating
real-world scenarios right so these
could be a fake earthquake that
potentially knocks out power to a data
center which of course we simulate
hopefully you know dropping the power to
the internet things like that there was
a day in the office where I showed up to
work the video conferencing cut mid
meeting somebody sent a text message
that said oh by the way the internet is
down for the next three hours
enjoy tell us what you did so we can
write it down for the actual plan going
forward and I say this as a Cavalier
story but really these teams are you
know these tests are designed to give
teams the ability to respond to
real-world scenarios and how they
respond to the tests test their plan of
action and also helps them improve their
plan of action for when real incidents
occur all right so talking about you
know again administrative actions right
what is Google doing to run a proper
HIPAA program proper health care
compliance program this is the list of
services covered by the BAA as of
sometime last week I would probably be
willing to say that it's already out of
date in that we continue to add more
services to the BAA
over time they're being added very
rapidly there's probably a couple more
that have been added in the last week
all right so when we talk about physical
safeguards facilities management right
so physical physical safeguards I won't
spend too much time talking about
because it really just depends on how do
we run our data centers how do we run
our offices when we talk about our data
centers our data centers are some of the
most protected buildings in the world
right they're protected by custom
designed electronic access cards alarms
perimeter defenses laser beam detection
imagine you know a heist movie anything
you see in that heist movie we probably
have it and there's probably some other
stuff in there that they won't show in
the movies all right safe to say
facility access is tightly controlled
only approved you know employees and
their guests and vendors potentially
people you know people who should be
there are there they're vetted before
they get there background checks are
done and so on all right technical
safeguards defense-in-depth I talked
about this this just kind of shows you
know our fundamental approach to
technical safeguards and then going into
some detail we have encryption by
default at rest and when I say by
default what do I mean what I mean is
customers don't have to check a box that
says turn on default encryption they
don't have to you know say what size
keys they want what level of encryption
what data stores are in scope for
encryption or not no data on rest on
Google cloud platform is encrypted this
is a sample of one layer of encryption
so different services different storage
applications have maybe multiple levels
of encryption this just kind of shows an
individual file coming into Google Cloud
and what happens here is that file is
broken into multiple pieces each of
these pieces is encrypted with its own
key then we wrap that key with a key
encryption key so that we don't store
keys in plaintext the keys are also
encrypted and then each of these files
and their encryption key is put into a
different physical system in many cases
right so this is this is basically
saying data is not only encrypted
it'sing it's split up encrypted and then
distributed across the infrastructure so
that a failure in any one machine or
multiple machines does not compromise
the integrity of the file it also means
that you know if for some hypothetical
case somebody got physical access to one
machine the probability that
a there's an entire file on that machine
is low and be all of the chunks are
encrypted with different keys so the
attack surface again defense-in-depth is
lowered with every step alright so when
we talk about encryption sorry endpoint
security Google on our end we use you
know devices that are updated centrally
they auto update they make sure that
there are strong security primitives on
the device and we also make these
devices and software's available to our
customers which we'll talk a little bit
about later and you know when we talk
about defense-in-depth one of the
easiest things an organization can do to
secure their technology to secure their
systems is have to factor a multi-factor
authentication in place right this helps
you know prevent against phishing this
helps add an additional layer of
auditing and logging and basically make
it so that the attack surface is again
reduced alright so now that we've talked
a little bit of an overview into how
Google secures our production systems
and makes services available to
customers I want to talk a little bit
about how customers should think about
their controls that are available to
them right not everything is going to be
handled by the cloud provider because
Google wants to give customers the
flexibility to build the systems that it
needs to build we don't know what data
you want your data schema you want we
don't know where you want it stored we
don't know what network setup you want
but what we do want to do is give you
the controls to do what it is you need
to do all right so I have a similar
diagram our philosophy of
defense-in-depth you know transcends our
own sphere of influence and we would
like to give customers that same ability
right so customers are working on
potentially the same level of controls
that we our customers care about
infrastructure security in some cases
but in our case we've taken care of that
one right so customers care about
network security care about data
security application security Identity
and Access Management endpoints
monitoring and operations and then of
course wrapping it nice and tight
together in that governance risk and
compliance framework right so the way I
think about this left column of
governance risk and compliance is
good documentation and policies around
everything else on the slide so if you
don't have good data security for
example your compliance is going to be
hard for you alright so this this is
kind of the the framework of protections
that are in place diving into a little
bit more detail but but first you know
touching again on shared security
because I really think that's a
fundamental consideration for this is
when we think about our infrastructure
services right Google has taken care of
the hardware how the underlying hardware
boots
what kernel it has how the data is
encrypted and stored how the audit
logging is done but then when we make
that guest OS right that is kind of the
layer at which the controls become
available to the customer do they want
Linux do they want Windows do they want
something else right something
proprietary and that's the level of
control to which customers you start at
on our infrastructure services if you
don't want that level of control if you
don't need that level of flexibility for
every system why not take advantage of
one of the platform as-a-service
solutions right and that's because
Google has again made more sane choices
about the security of those systems all
the way at up to potentially the
application itself in which case you can
drop in your business logic and you know
rest assured that the underlying
features have been accounted for and you
have less and less responsibility over
time and this translates also into our
software as a service solution so G
suite which encompasses Gmail Drive
right basically the only thing you're
doing in that case is managing the data
managing who can access the data and
managing who you share the data with all
right so going into those same
categories right where where do customer
responsibilities lie in identity and
access first we should talk about what
that means on Google cloud right I think
we can get a little bit into some of the
technical details here we can say that
on Google cloud there are two types of
may or two main types of identities
right we can have a human identity which
is me doing work as myself and we can
also have service accounts or what we
call robot identities that's like some
service doing work on
of a system on behalf of a group of
people serving an API doing cron jobs on
data basically things that a human
wanted to automate so they let a machine
and do it periodically
or a machine do it for the scope of
security the way these accounts
authenticate is different right so when
you have a human account you log onto
GCP you'll type in your username and
password you'll enter hopefully as you
should
your second factor or third factor of
authentication and then you will
function as yourself when you want to
authenticate to you know when a service
account wants to authenticate it's
provided a key and that key basically
says this is the you know this service
account is accredited for this
organization for this scope of
performing performing this scope of
operations and you know it's important
to note that at some point things become
similar right both humans and service
accounts need iam roles I am permissions
on resources in order to modify them in
order to use them things like that so
key key concept here right different
types of identity different types of
accounts are relevant to different
applications if you're doing an admin
operation you might want to use a human
account because it's an ad-hoc one-off
thing right if you're automating
something if you're providing a service
scoping down the exact service
operations to a robot account helps
maintain security and it helps maintain
security because that robot is scoped to
only a limited set of duties and it
can't override that scope all right
taking this one step further
right now we talked about manipulating
resources on Google Cloud what about
securing applications so Google takes
you know the identity model one step
further and has made something available
to customers called identity aware proxy
and and what this is is a load balancer
and proxy that sits in front of
applications and when a user request
comes in the ia P basically does a check
for who that user is what they're
entitled to do on the application and
those things have to match so not only
does it do you know identity based
controls it also does context controls
is is this user accessing the service
from an approved IP address
are they accessing the service from an
approved you know partner service so a
lot of these checks can be done at this
proxy layer and make sure that only
legitimate requests legitimate access
can make it into the backend application
all right so now talking about you know
user controls for encryption data
management and transmission protection
first remember when I showed you the
diagram about how Google encrypts data
by default well it turns out that's only
one of the encryption options available
on Google cloud and it's the the
leftmost one here what we call default
encryption so you know it's the same
diagram we have on the previous slide
just showcasing the other two options
for key management so maybe you know you
want a little bit more control than the
default encryption you want to specify
which keys are used to encrypt which
files how often those keys are rotated
when those keys are deleted and whether
you know any of the keys need to be
reused over time basically the default
encryption has made all of those
decisions for you and and offered it in
a managed service approach but if any
one of those decisions sounds like a
decision you need to make that's what
customer manage encryption keys are for
and what you do is you'd configure the
service say I would like to manage the
encryption keys when that service needs
to encrypt a file it will go to find the
key you specify encrypt it or decrypt it
and then put that key back there is an
even more controlled option called
customer supplied keys and what this
enables you to do is not store any of
the encryption keys on Google cloud so
both of the first option which is
default encryption and the second option
customer managed encryption keys store
the encryption keys in what we call
Google Cloud kms our key management
system if you want to store the
encryption keys on Prem then you can use
customer supplied encryption keys and
the way you would do that is in the API
request to access a file you specify the
encryption key and that file is
decrypted and set to you and the key is
not stored and the same thing works when
you're storing a file so you give it the
file you give it the encryption key you
want we perform our chunking and
encryption the same way we normally
would but we use your key and we
right afterwards so that you have to
keep supplying it the one thing I will
caveat with this is that this can be
difficult to get right you know it is
possible if you don't have a robust
existing key management service on Prem
or on another cloud system wherever
you're storing your keys you can encrypt
data we don't store the key and if you
don't store that key that data is
effectively gone right so it's like an
important to say that while this offers
more control it also offers more
responsibility all right so another
thing that you know you can use to
control the access and permissions
around data on cloud is V PC service
controls and what this allows you to do
is define a security perimeter around
Google cloud platform resources to
constrain data to that perimeter
basically you know control when data
leaves or comes into that security
perimeter and help mitigate data leaving
that perimeter so V PC has kind of three
main use cases right we talked about
we'll talk about mitigating data
exfiltration so what this diagram is
showing here is by setting up the
virtual perimeter you can prevent the
number of exfiltration pathways to only
what you want right so let's say that
you have a GCS bucket and you only want
it to be accessed within services in a
specific network but not by any services
outside of that network so what you
would do is you would put you know
configure the V PC is sorry service
controls so that the services that
should access the data are on the same
network and services that shouldn't
access the data are outside that and
then configure it such that it basically
Auto rejects anything coming in that
shouldn't that isn't already on that
network all right this is also a great
enabler for hybrid cloud you know hybrid
GCP hybrid with other clouds hybrid
cloud and on-premise cetera so you can
include on-prem resources in your V PC
network and what that will allow you to
do is securely access resources on
Google cloud from your on-premise
environment and vice versa so this is a
really good you know security control
for making it you for extending your
on-premise network to cover Google Cloud
again and vice-versa all right and
lastly combined with identity aware
proxy VPC is also an important service
for enforcing context aware access right
so in in this case it's not only the
identity of the accessing service or the
individual that matters it's also the
context for which they're applying for
access so you can say it's like where's
this user located maybe you have you
know data for some of your users that
needs to stay within a certain network
boundary right you don't want it to
leave their organization's network but
you know that it may potentially need to
be accessed from one of your partner
organizations and that access is allowed
so in this case you can set up your
default network to be restricted to one
organization block IP addresses outside
that but you can also allow you know
accesses from IP addresses belonging to
your partner organization which both
allows you the you know flexibility to
work with your partners as well as
having the security of having data in
the system all right so talking about
audit and activity logging one of the
ways Google has kind of helped aggregate
all of the audit and activity logs is
through cloud security command center
was what cloud security command center
does is it you know scans through your
Google cloud platform resources detects
and responds to threats in the system
and also you know aggregates those for
you so when you think about you know
issues like misconfigured access
policies misconfigured network policies
public storage buckets you know issues
that are basically fundamental security
checks that you want to be conducting
all the time cloud security command
center is the service that would be
conducting those checks and then
surfacing that data to your you know to
your admins to the project owners to
make sure that the events are caught as
early as possible
one of the the cool things about you
know cloud security command center is it
was built for a hybrid environment right
so we know that people here don't
necessarily just have Google cloud
platform resources people have made
investments into on-prem technologies
people are using multi cloud and those
don't disappear the moment you start
using GCP right so we know that we've
built a number of detectors that
function well with our native cloud
platform tools but we also integrate
with a number of partners who you may
already be using who you may consider
using and we also have capabilities to
put your own monitoring data in cloud
security command center and make it that
holistic audit and logging tool for
getting security and monitoring insights
into the organization all right so you
know getting getting towards the end of
the audit and activity logging session I
think most people here know about cloud
audit logging they know about access
transparency to summarize cloud audit
logging logs your organization's
activities on your data and access
transparency logging logs the cloud
providers actions on your data so this
could be something like an approved
Support Activity you know a bug ticket
you file for a service if somebody at
Google needs to go in and help you
resolve that ticket you'll get an access
transparency log that says this ticket
was resolved we had to access this
project for this reason and you can
basically track everything in one place
all right so how we tie this all
together right so we know that Google
has some responsibilities customers have
some responsibilities it's important to
showcase how all of this works and I'll
do this in two parts so I'll show you
the cloud health care API which is kind
of a managed service for data
aggregation data storage data processing
on Google cloud for health care data and
I'll also show you how that service can
fit into a larger organization
architecture with an alignment on HIPAA
compliance okay so overview into the
cloud healthcare API the cloud like I
said the cloud healthcare API implements
industry standard protocols and formats
in this case you know DICOM data for
radiology records for medical imaging
data
fire which is for electronic health
records text let's say and hl7 which is
for clinical messaging right and what we
use the cloud or what we hope the cloud
healthcare API will help enable is
accelerated ingestion storage analysis
and integration of healthcare data with
cloud based applications what do I mean
by that so the healthcare API provides a
secure gateway from an off cloud system
into advanced capabilities on Google
cloud like bigquery for analysis
tensorflow for ml ml engine for more ml
because you can never have too much ml
and and together you know we hope that
this this - link and this product helps
you aggregate your data in cloud and
make it available across modalities
across formats for holistic views of
patients for you know to enable better
research and care ok how does the
healthcare API look right so the
healthcare API is just very similar to
other cloud storage services it is an
API that sits in a region so think of
you know London or LA or something like
that and within that healthcare API
region you have a data set and that data
set consists of multiple stores or
buckets of different types of healthcare
data so the interesting things to note
here is a lot of the HIPAA compliance
responsibilities have been taken care of
for you right so the storage layer is
done a lot of the networking layer is
done and the encryption layer comes with
the storage layer is also done and the
other thing to notice here is that data
is aggregated across different
modalities in a single data set right so
we have text data that's structured we
have image data that's structured pixel
data and text and we have clinical
messages and all of those in one data
set helps enable different applications
right so let's imagine that you're
trying to retrieve medical imaging data
for care or for creating AI or ML models
what you might want to do here is use
the healthcare API as that connection
piece between an on-premise PACs or a
DICOM router a DICOM router is basically
just a fancy
for something that speaks reads writes
medical imaging format DICOM and
connects different systems together and
then on the other side of that
healthcare api you have you know your
analytics and ml modules your
application ecosystem potentially this
is where you know you let partners
access data you let patients access data
and you know anything in between when we
talk about hl7 important in the clinical
space not necessarily much outside that
but basically you know it's the way that
different devices and operations within
a hospital communicate with each other
so if I'm a patient hooked up to a
glucose monitor or a blood pressure cuff
hl7 would be the format by which updates
for my condition gets sent to the my
canonical patient record and what we've
done is we've turned this kind of weird
proprietary hl7 format into structured
JSON right and what that does is helps
make it available for analytics research
you name it all right so where is this
all going right why why is this
important to the HIPAA Security
presentation is that what we're doing
with the healthcare API is translating
data in multiple formats to a canonical
standard format and then making that
data available to the rest of Google
Cloud all of the rest of the Google
Cloud HIPAA compliant or HIPAA aligned
services and what this enables is it
enables you to reduce the burden of
setting this up yourself it enables you
to reduce the burden of setting up the
security and compliance for you know
this translation layer for the storage
layer yourself and then lets you
concentrate on doing what I would call
core business activities right I think
in a lot of cases security is table
stakes for an organization security is
something you have to get right but
security is not the end goal right like
why are we securing data is so we can do
something with it and and that something
can be researched that something can be
patient care that something can be you
know improving the quality of treatments
but securing the data for the sake of
security is generally not the end goal
and what we're doing here is is wrapping
that security layer into
I guess product layer that can do other
things all right I think talking about
you know what what some people consider
the holy grail of research is being able
to see longitudinal patient data from
multiple sources in multiple formats in
one place
I'm not saying we've solved it I'm just
saying there's a possibility that it can
be done right so it's like you have data
from multiple formats you want to get it
into the healthcare API and then you
want to turn it into bigquery which is
where you'll get your you know sequel
friendly query language across all of
these domains which used to have
different formats all right from a
security purpose maybe you want to
de-identify your data before you share
it with other people the healthcare API
supports you know native
de-identification
of data in these fire formats so what
we've done is we've taken the structure
of fire parsed it and said you know we
know this field contains patient names
so if you want to take out patient names
we can do that we know some fields
contain dates if those dates need to be
removed to protect patient privacy or
shift it to maintain patient privacy we
can do that what's not shown here is
free text right so free text is another
there long strings of provider notes we
can do that as well
it just isn't on this slide talking
about doing that in DICOM DICOM files
contain patient data in metadata or
sorry patient information and metadata
which you see in the top left and right
and patient data burnt into the pixel
data right in the in the middle bottom
our D identification tools can also
strip that up and thinking about HIPAA
compliance this is a fundamental ability
in you know data processing and data
protection right so when you're sending
data between organizations one of the
things that's important to HIPAA is data
is protected in transit and one of the
ways you can protect patient data in
transit is to not send any patient data
in the first place so D identifying the
files before they're sent you know
between organizations before they're
published is a great way to kind of meet
the HIPAA requirements while still
meeting the business requirements all
right finally tying
all together right how can something
like this look so the sample that I have
here is the user journey is you have
some data that exists off of Google
Cloud perhaps this is on pram and a Colo
in your own data center on a third-party
infrastructure on another cloud on a
managed service provider there's quite a
number of options here right and you
want to move that data to cloud get a
canonical data storage platform then
make that data available to research
partners to your own organization to
third-party services and anything in
between but at the same time maintain
HIPPA right that's kind of the the key
methodology here or maintain gdpr
right like the controls can change but
the intent stays the same so the way I
broken this up here is into for what we
call GCP projects right and that's the
data ingestion project the data storage
and analysis project the data sharing
project and the monitoring and auditing
project I've included some underlying
management services here like our
logging platform our I am platform what
we call our stack driver services for
debugging and monitoring not because
they're in a separate project but just
because they underlie you know all of
the other ones and I didn't want to
duplicate them in all of the above so
okay so now we've talked about the use
case right why is why is this use case
relevant this is what we think as one of
the fundamental user journeys for a
cloud you know cloud migration right you
will want to take data from multiple
disparate sources ingest it normalize it
aggregate it and then make it available
for use cool all right so breaking this
down into individual steps right and how
does HIPAA kind of interplay in all of
these things so this is our first
project data ingestion so that the data
ingestion layer is you know where you'll
move raw patient data on to Google Cloud
perform in ETL operation extract
transform and load
and basically change that data from one
format in its native on-premise format
to a cloud native format and here are
the protections that would be in place
are is its temporary storage its
ephemeral machines that are doing
transformation and it's on a separate
network because we don't want you know
that network to be then the network that
goes from on-premise to cloud we don't
want to contaminate it by giving it
access too far alright now that we've
ingested and normalized the data we
probably want to move it to a canonical
data store right and here is what some
people would call a data Lake a data
aggregation layer it does storage it
does analysis it might be where you
serve some of the ML applications it
writes logs to the audit project and
most importantly no external network
connectivity right so this this means
that your network for this application
is locked down to only your organization
it means that the core data layer is
only accessible by services and service
accounts that are providing you know
those service accounts may be providing
public services but no public access to
this project directly for obvious
reasons but you know there does come a
time when you do want to provide
services externally this you know in
some cases can be done in a different
project this may be done in a different
VP see here we've shown it as you know
both right it's in a different project
with its own network this project can
connect through service accounts to the
data aggregation layer and it can also
connect to external services right so
this being maybe you want to serve an ml
model publicly so this service would
expose a public endpoint somebody can
make an API request to it it would then
send a service account back to this
project that service account request
would go grab something from the
underlying data set it would bring it
back to this project aggregate it and
shared publicly so what what we've you
know left out so far
the big component of HIPAA is
centralized logging and monitoring right
if any patient data is touched there
should be a log entry if that log entry
is flagged there needs to be manual
auditing of the activity to make sure
that it was legitimate or illegitimate
and appropriate actions taken afterwards
right so what this project is doing is
kind of simplifying all that monitoring
for you I won't say for you but it's
simplifying all that monitoring in one
place so all of the other projects are
sending audit logs here all of the other
projects are sending system logs here
monitoring data and then in this project
you would put you know your your rules
your triggers your alerts your
notifications such that not only is it
seeing activity from individual projects
it's also seeing activity holistically
right so it can it can account for
trends across different things in the
environment and the the benefit of
aggregating all these logs together is
specifically that right is like now you
get access to full trends to patterns to
longitudinal accesses and and how data
moves throughout the system whereas if
you were just looking at logs from a
single project you wouldn't get that
okay this is probably some I guess of my
opinions on best practices for audit
logging it's you know is what we
recommend for internal teams it's what
we recommend to some of our customers
and partners as well it's you know turn
on data access logging so cloud we know
has two forms of audit logging admin
activity which is on by default and data
access logging which captures access to
data so turn on data access logging for
services that are holding pH I write set
up audit log export we talked about that
and why it's important and configure
access control for logs appropriately
right like there's you want to avoid the
situation where somebody who did
malicious things to your data can then
go delete the audit logs for that and
lastly you actually want to look at the
audit logs also obvious okay this this
process right of making a HIPAA aligned
project architecture is something that
is not impossible
but it is common right and and when our
team looked at all of these activities
and said you know what are the things
that go into making a HIPAA align
project it was basically things like
controlling access controlling
encryption controlling Network
boundaries controlling audit logs so
what we did was we created a set of
open-source tooling were unofficially
calling it the data protection toolkit
and it allows for infrastructure as code
deployment of projects that are designed
to meet some sort of organizational
regulatory compliance requirements right
so it leverages deployment manager which
is a HIPAA aligned service and you know
soon to be terraformed which is a
popular open-source toolkit as well what
what this actually does is it aggregates
you know an entire scope of HIPAA
activities into one toolkit so what
you'll do is you'll define you know what
resources you want you want some compute
some storage some networking and you'll
define the controls that you want in
place you know some resources shouldn't
be public some resources should prevent
data access some resources should
generate more logs than others and some
resources should be allowed to be shared
right so you're basically there's a
controls library and a resources library
and you will choose the specific scope
of resources you're interested in and
the specific scope of policies are
interested in and this service will
automatically deploy them and create a
GCP project at the same time as doing so
it will also put a continuous monitoring
framework around those resources and
what that continuous monitoring
framework will do is periodically
interrogate the resources you set up
against the policies that you set up and
give you data that data can be you know
yes everything's good or that data can
be here's a violation you should
probably look into it and what that
enables is you know to meet the HIPAA
requirements of audit and monitoring
kind of all from one continuous tool
chain why why did we choose you know for
SETI for the monitoring engine so for
those of you who aren't familiar with
for SETI security it's a native
open-source tooling for Google cloud
that builds an inventory of project
scans it repeatedly and periodically for
a set of policies and in a certain case
of policies you know actually enforces
against malicious changes so if you set
an inventory you know in when we think
back to here if you said in the
deployment stage
you want three VMs and two storage
buckets this inventory is going to get
created and hopefully it should contain
three VMs and two storage buckets and if
it doesn't contain three bm's into
storage buckets that scanner is going to
pick it up and send you an alert so you
can go back and correct it right now and
all of this over time is kind of saying
you know if you defined your HIPAA
policies a certain way as your
organization grows you may need more
resources but new resources that you
create will be under the same policy
framework that you set up originally all
right
so you know why we think this this
tooling is helpful to customers right
it's a secure what we call quick start
as I was saying security is not is it is
fundamentally important but it's not
necessarily the end goal right so this
is a framework to help you know people
get up and running quickly on GCP by
creating predictable consistent secure
workloads that then let you do your
business requirements so this is saying
you know if you have to create identical
development testing and production
environments to run a medical device
because that's the regulatory framework
you know this tool will allow you to
write one template run it three times
the other thing it allows you to do is
if you know you have a canonical data
layer and you want to give researchers
or partners access to that data and you
want to give it to them in a lockdown
environment these templates will let you
spin up lockdown identical environments
for each research group that's accessing
the data and the other thing is because
this is an infrastructure as code
framework it's easy to share these
templates across teams and across
institutions all right so now you know
talking about some customers who are
successfully running HIPAA aligned
workloads on Google cloud you know three
examples generally come to mind that
showcase the range of activities so we
have you know the University of Colorado
health data compass has used Google
cloud to achieve
compliance on a data warehouse and this
has helped them you know reduce query
times from many hours to just a few
minutes and has helped them you know cut
operating costs and make their research
programs more scalable and this is again
you know following the model of shared
responsibility so previously they were
managing all of this on Prem by moving
their infrastructure to Google cloud
they cut their compliance
responsibilities by a significant
portion and realized other benefits at
the same time leading to you know faster
research yeah
so you know second example you'll start
to see a trend develop right move
workloads to cloud helps reduce
responsibility helps reallocate more
bandwidth money energy time to other
activities leading to the acceleration
of the core business requirements so
specifically for the NIH National
Institutes on Aging you know they were
able to process 200 terabytes of data in
just a few weeks which would normally
have taken them months right and this is
a this is an institution that had
hardware that was potentially older they
use the same amount of funds on cloud
based hardware and process that data
much faster and lastly you know the
Broad Institute is doing genomic
analysis on Google cloud and moving
their infrastructure here has helped
them you know accelerate the analysis of
human genomes by 400% they have
instituted new and different security
protections than they were able to do on
Prem and again the trend continues right
allocated resources better led to more
efficient research patterns and with
that thank you for joining us today and
I'll be around to take any questions
[Music]